in advance of his forty two to one
thirty four thirty and say to Buster
Douglas thank you for helping me not
study that day Buster Douglas you don't
hold it against me that it was at the
University of Michigan though right
buster yeah good we're good
okay that's very good so what are your
recollections today what would you say
if somebody did not somehow know what
had happened to you what would you tell
them about your story on that and that
night against Mike Tyson Buster tell
them it was a great moment you should
have been there should have seen it why
I guess so been there all the way in
Tokyo what what do you remember about
that day
when you woke up that morning Buster so
I'm pretty excited you know little
anxious but relax you're confident so
confidently you'll be a big day and
driving to the what was it like driving
to the Tokyo Dome that morning what was
going through your mind more excitable
than any other fight because of the
heavyweight championship and it was my
second shot at the title and I felt
really good throughout the whole whole
course of the training other than the
person in my mom but everything else was
blowing really well
well I if I do recall you know your mom
Lulu pearl passed away 23 days before
the fight and many of your folks in your
camp were saying you shouldn't fight
this fight because you were still
grieving no I didn't tell me that they
didn't say that to me but I saw they
would ask me how I felt I told myself
good I was always ready Joe even more
than timing you know because we talked
before she passed and I knew that one of
I made her feel good as soon I was
unable to continue this Oliver passing
and though she was on the Super's I and
she went to make sure also as she was
like telling me and my brothers you know
looked after us man and
I know it's nice being strong for her as
well were you at all afraid going in
that ring buster cuz everybody who is
fighting Tyson those days had some look
in their eyes and I'm wondering if you
have no more no more than the other
fight well it was a difference of Lord
more intense than the other particles
everywhere championship but other than
that it was love it was a normal thing
where you don't kill all let it
overwhelm you where you can't perform
you know we've been in the game long
enough to know that you know now it
wouldn't allow that to happen you know
even though with Mike Tyson are still
remain the last you know because I
believed in my abilities I had a great
training and training session so I was
pretty confident you know I was pissed -
so what I mean you're pissed I was upset
and everything that was going on in my
life was coming in chaos and I knew that
it would had to be something special on
the other hand because it was like
everyday man something with the farmer
and with another disaster fee another
disaster you know I was like and I just
think doing like this had to be in my
time because it's like every day it
seemed like it was something new you
know to get upset about or keep
disappointing you know but I stay in
focus or maintain well what what
happened what was other growing things
things going on in your life is it
people might you know really enough
separating you know and then you know
just things of that nature you know you
know family squabbles and stuff but you
know just you know in the other time
that was in training camp you'd be a
smooth training camp but this time well
I felt really focused and and confident
that there was going to be a great great
day you know it was like every other day
will seem like it was something that a
little nag that will come up but you
know I seen through it and just staying
focused but you know the biggest blow of
course it was my mom passed but that
just made it even you know more
realistic
time to stay focused tomorrow no priors
Buster Douglas here in the Rich Eisen
show 42 to one premieres Tuesday at 9:00
Eastern Time on ESPN co-directed by my
good friend Jeremy shap Buster were you
aware that nobody gave you shot I mean
and if so how how do ya know that was
obvious I mean you know caduceus he is a
destroyer you know and it was like if he
wasn't decapitating people you had no
chance against this man so I know
everybody felt about it but I just
maintained beliefs to my splitting
myself of my abilities well I mean you
got a good story of somebody coming up
to you and saying you had no shot like
directly to your face you got anything
good on that that was every day man
especially at a New Year's Eve party it
was like oh my gosh
what do you mean you know despite my
ties in there's really oh my oh my gosh
I mean it was one girl at one party that
I was attending and she was like looking
at me kinda you know you know the memory
and I was like what's out well and I
walked up to her she said man you must
be desperate I said what he must be
justified in mind if he's fighting Mike
Tyson oh wow you know but that's how I
was you know just like I said he wasn't
taking someone's head off or tips of my
head out and had no chance against this
man in anybody else's eyes that's how I
seen it well I was confident I would
just laugh and just you know shrug my
shoulders and keep it moving
do you have any relationship with Mike
today Buster Douglas
no no what would you say to him if you
saw him like last time we were together
was a couple of years ago just outside
of DC at autograph-signing it was
pleasant pleasant conversation as you
know he's been doing is pretty hanging
in there you know those are the general
conversations that was the best time
that we ever spent together since the
fight you know conversate conversating
and stuff other than that you know we
haven't really been around each other do
you wish you had fought him instead of
Evander obviously we know
back in the day you were pissed at him
and Don King for for contesting the
results based on an eighth round that
was a mess but you know I have no
regrets you know shoulda woulda coulda
you know I'm just glad I'm healthy and
feel my life is in good shape and I'm
moving on okay what do you think of the
Deontay Wilder Tyson Fury match anyway
fighter battled man it came in from good
shape and they they they gave it their
all very very put up a good fight you
know about the art a man that guy stays
focus man he didn't Kevin he didn't he
didn't slack he he got his opportunity
later fighting took advantage I was in
one he pulled it out so he was
definitely down on all those cards you
know he was gonna lose everyone who went
into the 12 round because uh theory was
doing a great job of boxing and keeping
him at bay kept his hands moving in his
feet move in there but he just got
caught up and Dante got him you know
maintaining it yeah they showed a lot of
poise you know he maintained its focus
and uh got him in the end when his
opportunity presented itself so do you
think fury got the benefit of the doubt
getting a count with him clearly being
out even though he got up Undertaker
style Buster what do you think no you
know the count you know here we go take
a yeah you know the count was the count
you know he'd beat the count
you know so I thought he can do it he
did with these possibilities listen it's
only official County gonna go on and let
the referee says and he got to County
got up before the rubber account of the
can you know he tried kept trying to
fight but he went on was the warrior
I'll tell you he was a great show good
heavyweight fight man I was glad to see
it yeah do you think the heavyweights
divisions back buster interesting things
coming up now some seeing was good
happen with this mix now back in the
ball back in the other champions corner
now Joshua so we'll see what happened so
on forty two to one premiering Tuesday
night at 9:00 Eastern Time on on ESPN we
noticed you went back to the Tokyo Dome
is that the first time you went back
there yeah that was pretty that was
interesting you have to walk around
downtown Tokyo all over and stuff it was
pretty interesting hmm I see where they
built it up to the mounting an amusement
park was sorry the Tokyo Dome well I
mean that let's call that the amusement
park Buster Douglas built I mean let's
just go for right there I mean so what
was what was going through your mind as
you walked into that building where your
life changed I was like man is just
really good ready to happen you know a
lot of questions man like should I
really be here You Know Who am I
I don't know well Buster thanks for the
time I appreciate it I look forward to
seeing this whole story that was a
remarkable day in the Tokyo Dome I'll
never forget where I was watching it
that was unbelievable you got me up you
got everybody up and and freaking out so
I appreciate you joining so you've got a
great show man she loved to work thanks
buster I appreciate that right back at
you that's Buster Douglas calling in
from Columbus Ohio the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience